it's the biggest single weapon in the
American armed forces in fact no other
Navy in the world has anything quite
like it it's also one of the most
complex and technically advanced pieces
of engineering on earth and we've got an
all-access pass to the flight deck the
cockpit even the captain's chair of the
USS Ronald Reagan we're about to
discover the technology operating this
super carrier has a mobile combat
airport
and a floating home for more than 5,000
sailors like President Reagan himself
this supercarriers motto is peace
through strength
but this ship is more than strong it's
mobile
unlike ground troops a carrier can head
anywhere in the world quickly and easily
by sailing through international waters
we can take this Carrier Strike Group
anywhere in the world that we want to
with only the permission of the
President of the United States
this massive marine monster is perfectly
designed for one task launch and land
fighter jets anywhere in the world
the Reagan's current mission prowl the
waters of the western Pacific Ocean near
Korea it's a demonstration of force
establishing American presence in a
troubled area
it's no wonder adversaries show respect
when this super carrier shows up it's
got plenty of size speed and manpower
the USS Ronald Reagan is 1090 six feet
long nearly as long as the Empire State
Building is tall it towers 20 stories
high fully loaded
it weighs ninety seven thousand tons and
this mammoth ship is also a speedster
able to exceed 30 knots or 35 miles per
hour to keep it all running the Reagan
House is a crew of five to six thousand
commanded by Captain Terry craft I tell
people I managed a nuclear power plant
with an airport on top and 5,000 people
squeezed in between that's life on an
aircraft carrier
the USS Ronald Reagan is the newest and
most advanced of nine nuclear power
Nimitz class super carriers the largest
warships in the world and it's got a
price tag to match four and a half
billion dollars aircraft carriers are
built for the long haul so I really do
think you get your money's worth out of
an aircraft carrier you know the last
commanding officer of USS Ronald Reagan
has not been born yet the ships designed
to last for 50 years despite the
billions of dollars of technology built
into this super carrier the ship is
still run by human hands and the heart
of the action is the flight deck crew a
team of 400 highly trained sailors they
have to remain focused and rely on well
honed procedures this flight deck is
filled with roaring jet engines massive
machinery and dangerous weapons
[Music]
in the carriers most dangerous
situations one team is on the frontline
the EOD explosive Ordinance Disposal
from diffusing a damaged bomb to
handling unexploded ammunition Zod
takes the greatest risks of anyone on
the ship our motto is initial success or
total failure and that summarizes pretty
much what we do one task defusing
underwater mines requires a helo cast a
Seahawk helicopter ride deep into the
open ocean
out here miles from the carrier the team
runs an intense drill jumping into the
water
then climbing back into the low-flying
helicopter
[Music]
obviously there's some risk but it's a
challenge that's fun to do to work with
some of those guys jump them out of the
helo and then pick them up
when the ammo is gone and the last
aircraft mission has been flown the USS
Ronald Reagan heads for home these
sailors have been at sea for more than
three months and they're ready for the
deployment to end how's your family
doing we have been under way a lot the
hard part about that that you just can't
get around it's hard on the families so
we're looking forward to getting home
but it won't be long before the USS
Ronald Reagan the world's largest mobile
combat airport is back out at sea and
when it's prowling the oceans
adversaries will have to take notice of
this ultimate weapon for years to come
this super carrier will send a message
to the world the same message delivered
by the president whose name it carries
peace through strength